. As if Donald Trump needed any more scandals,
this could be the scandal of all scandals.
We have learned that the Justice Department
is investigating a possible cash for Trump
pardons scheme.
Understand what this means.
The idea is there are people out there who
want to be pardoned by Donald Trump before
Trump leaves office in about seven weeks.
The idea that is being investigated is that
you could pay someone to go and talk to Trump
about pardoning you.
And it is absolutely and utterly insane.
We knew Trump would issue corrupt and erroneous
pardons.
He did so with Michael.
And last week, he did so with Roger Stone
some months ago, but a cash for pardons scandal
is another level altogether.
And we learned about the existence of this
investigation because of the release of some
very redacted court documents that called
this a bribery for pardons scheme.
A ton of the 18 page document that was released,
a ton of it is blacked out.
It's redacted.
Entire swaths, large sections, even almost
whole pages blacked out.
Nobody who is involved has yet been named
in the redacted documents.
Presumably they are named in the unredacted
documents.
But what the document does say is that federal
prosecutors in Washington say they've obtained
evidence of a bribery scheme in which someone
would offer a big political contribution in
exchange for a presidential pardon or reprieve
of sentence.
The order said.
Prosecutors were also investigating a secret
lobbying scheme in which two unidentified
individuals would lobby senior White House
officials about pardons without disclosing
that, without being registered properly.
As part of the Lobbying Disclosure Act, the
Justice Department wanted to keep this private
because it detailed individuals and conduct
that hasn't yet led to charges.
And it is an absolutely insane series of allegations.
Now, I want to be really clear.
Just because the pardons would ultimately
be issued by Donald Trump doesn't mean that
this was people giving Trump money for pardons.
It's really important that we understand that.
It wouldn't be surprising to me, given Trump's
massive debts, if people were offering Trump
money for pardons.
That's not what we as of now believe is going
on.
The idea for now seems to be that if you want
a pardon, you pay someone that someone goes
and talks to senior White House officials,
the idea being the White House officials then
go to Trump and maybe never disclose that
there is this whole bribery situation going
on and say, hey, sir, Mr. President, you should
really look at pardoning this person or that
person.
So it's still very early, but my mind goes
to how bad must this be if Donald Trump's
own attorney general, William Barr's DOJ,
is investigating?
And what I mean by that is William Barr is
one of the most corrupt attorneys general
we've ever seen in terms of political cronyism
and partizanship even William Barr had to
say there's no evidence of widespread voter
fraud, which we covered earlier today.
I can't imagine that William Barr would be
eager to bring charges for criminal pardon
bribery.
But for William Barr to even have his Justice
Department investigating this means that there
has been a relatively high threshold met already.
This entire issue of pardons, of course, is
a bigger issue.
You know, imagine a president ordering people
to assassinate a political enemy and then
pardoning them as an example.
The entire pardon process and infrastructure
is riddled with corruption, cronyism, and
lends itself to all sorts of all sorts of
malfeasance.
But we are now getting to investigations that
are the types of things you see more often
in developing and poorer countries, not typically
the United States, but it's at least possibly
happening here, scandal after scandal after
scandal.
And, you know, we've got seven weeks left.
What will we learn about in these last seven
weeks, what will Trump do in these last seven
weeks?
And then once he's out of office, what are
we going to learn?
I don't believe that we will ever see Trump
indicted, prosecuted or jailed, as many of
my viewers would like to see and as some of
my viewers believe will happen.
But I do believe that there is going to be
another shoe that drops after Donald Trump
is out of office about all sorts of allegations
of things he and the people around him did.
And a lot of this explains why Donald Trump
is now considering pardoning preemptively
his own children, son in law and Rudy Giuliani.
We will talk about that after the break.
In the meantime, make sure you're following
me on Instagram at David Pakman.
Also, follow the show on Instagram for more
clips and extra content.
The David Pakman Show
on Instagram,